[Musik]
julia häuser ron ist ausgebildete
schauspielerin am theater hora in zürich
[Musik]
julia hat ein down-syndrom
und julia ist verliebt in ihren
schauspielkollegen renault er ist autist
[Musik]
beide leben noch im elternhaus julia und
remo sind seit zwei jahren ein paar
jetzt reisen sie das erste mal ohne
eltern in die ferien
die mütter begleiten sie nur bis zum
flughafen
[Musik]
unter bart moser zum vater und auch noch
später
das
julia ist 22 und 24 jahre alt
ich sag's stärke ist natürlich das ja
juli
im hotel sind julia und remo teil einer
reisegruppe für leute mit geistigen und
körperlichen einschränkungen
da sehen wir doch super
das fontane archiv
[Musik]
ich behandle und wer irgendwo über
typische arbeit oder willst du aber
behindert aussteller was das kann ich
also mit wenig heißt autismus dass sich
so eine art angst angst vor
us-dollar um eine kann man sehr schnell
gefordert wird dann traut man sich
weniger oder wenn man merkt man wie
danken
warum ich gerade ganz gut über und dann
braucht man nicht um jemanden frage wie
es weitergeht aber das ist mir jetzt
nicht so schlimm
das war früher finde ich schön
also ich mit dem material kann ich es
gut dass ich mit dem fehler gang vors
gesicht als er wie immer wird sie gut
posco collins und das kirche bereit ist
jetzt gebe ich alles
das gemacht was einfach mal so gemacht
mit seinem wirken mag sie wirklich mit
höherer damit mir der christ sein
grades und jetzt nachts der straße genau
so also alles gut nach starker zweiter
die gott wieder
[Musik]
schnell
kairo
die theatergruppe hurra ist seit bald
sechs jahren mehrere wochen im jahr
weltweit auf tournee
bis jetzt in über 20 ländern in europa
süd und nordamerika und in asien
alle im ensemble haben eine geistige
oder körperliche beeinträchtigung
allein mit dem stück dies reduzierter
sind sie fast 200 mal aufgetreten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
julia
[Musik]
warum behält der französische choreograf
hat mit der gruppe das erfolgreiche
stück des reduzierter inszeniert nach
fast sechs jahren gibt es immer noch
anfragen
wir haben noch auftritte in paris und
ich habe gehört dass uns berlin nochmals
eingeladen hat wahrscheinlich werden wir
auch in zürich ein weiteres mal
auftreten
wir werden sehen egal ich freue mich
über jede aufführung okay lasst uns
weitermachen
am anfang konnte julia mit jerome bel
gar nichts anfangen
inzwischen hat sie sich an ihn gewöhnt
[Gelächter]
sie war von beginn an eine sehr
kraftvolle darstellerin weil sie weil
sie es einfach liebt
sie ist wie ein fisch im wasser
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir fanden es toll großartig unglaublich
das beste was ich je gesehen habe
es war großartig sehr speziell
ich habe so etwas das erste mal gesehen
sehr inspirierend auf
das spiel kostet
toll sagt wenn man beliebt energie
benötigt versteckt was verschiedene
gründe
das bringt zu sein und danke das
und so so so habe ich die mädchen
das
die schauspieler sind fantastisch und
sie sind wie soll ich sagen
sie sind wie wir und ich mag sie
nach vier jahren beziehung dürfen julia
und dämmung in eine gemeinsame wohnung
ziehen dem schreibtisch und mit einem
bett hatte die möglichkeit
für boston bruins zu zeigen welche wir
in funktion und so helga rother auch in
holz ich denke es wird besser wenn man
sieben zügen sie dient sicher extrem
aufpassen und und das ist mein geschäft
lief wie sie verstört und noch immer
dass unser partner wählt oder und das
meiner frau und mir mit
ich war die große liebe vor mit der
unterwäsche t shirt
das brächte das wird zusammen
dieser anteil lag wie durch problem
außerhalb bin jetzt schon über posten
hanni nanni gespürt
ja ich sehe diese kopf mit dem café dank
dafür ist aber wohl trotzdem musst hier
wie sie doch bloß ein haustier junge er
ist wieso hörbaren komplizen andere
[Musik]
kräfte und und die verprügelt sache
[Applaus]
ich bin lange noch
ja das ist natürlich vom zu schwierige
frage
ich find's einfach mit zehn mann hinten
bekommt und ja es für tiere auf diesem
posten
ich grüße euch danken
[Musik]
ich wollte
wann das kind mit down syndrom
so war sie als mutter und ebenfalls
vater zum beispiel einfach hoffnungslos
überschuldet dass es wird nie ein freund
nicht da wo es noch eine mittragen
also frauen dass sie ihre
schauspielkarriere komplett duftlinie
hier ein unternehmen in singapur hat
glück begeistert
ich danke das ist ein haus einmal aber
sie können ja ja ja
ja genau es ist ja nicht so dass ich
treffe ihn voll machen oder systemen
kraft nicht unten aber danke frank
schmerz ein
die eltern wussten vor der geburt das
ihr drittes kind mit einem down syndrom
zur welt kommen würde das irgendwie
einfach der gedanke das mundstück
gebäude wo nicht angezogen haben zu
einem für mich ist das ein klacks ich
wette nettes hintertrieben also als mini
umkleide ich werde nicht wie gold für
mich ist das nicht die frage also ich
wieviel als komplett ohne grenzen und
dann dass ich meine hand alles nicht so
platini hindeutet so spaziert sind oder
so droht klären und er hat enorm aus
strande natürlich mit vielen schönen
aber es hat ja niemand in seiner klinik
schafe
[Musik]
hurra
manches vorschlag befasst
ich hoffe dass dort wird er sechster bei
etwa so wie du und ist nur mit dir
wichtig aus spielerin sondern dass das
hat sich ihre sporen entwickelt es sich
durchaus möglich dass spannend wie es
ist eine premiere eine richtige theater
premiere zum ersten mal ist der
renommierte alfred kerr darstellerpreis
an eine schauspielerin mit geistiger
behinderung vergeben worden und zwar an
die schweizerin julia häusermann vom
theater hora
die 20 jährige hat ihren preis heute in
berlin im rahmen des theatertreffens
entgegengenommen
geehrt wurde die junge frau mit down
syndrom ihre rolle im stück des e book
väter von regisseur jérôme bel junge
häusermann und das ensemble haben mit
dem stück und diverse internationale
bühnen bespielt unter anderem in
südkorea
[Applaus]
seinem ex manager
immer wieder steht sie auch mit ihrem
verlobten auf der bühne am festival
zürich tanzt bekommen sie eine karte
renault hat die musik ausgewählt julia
wird spontan dazu tanzen
in den straßen aus
wirklich
wir haben jetzt für mich 14
falls der toskanischen dorfs veräußerung
des brand- oder nicht noch mal eine
chance gibt das tablet über das finden
[Musik]
das was ich durch und lustig sein wie
sie stoff sagt er habe jetzt nicht immer
von der anderen
[Musik]
mm
si
[Musik]
die karte
dann ist das ganze jetzt erstmal auf die
rückgabe kann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
performance machen sich jetzt erfüllt
mir da und einmalig
dass ich angst
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in new york ist julia 2014 nominiert für
den best award dem oscar für tanz
[Musik]
bern
diese dürften
die band hat
[Musik]
ende
[Applaus]
[Musik]
o
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin nicht gern
julia und dämmung sind seit fünf jahren
ein paar und leben inzwischen in einer
eigenen wohnung im alltag erhalten die
beiden regelmäßig unterstützung vom
sozialpädagogen und sie haben schon ein
hochzeitsdatum festgelegt
[Musik]
ja
und zweimal als 70 geschäfte bioacid zum
wochen- und allgemein zur sachen
halogen- oder mittwoch und einfach nur
pascal bringer vor sind budget von der
stiftung wie hanspeter gass den vortritt
der frankfurt habe und sie war
frankreichs nacht pro person
er hat sich das mal vorstellen
nein darüber haupt nicht was kann man
noch verbessern ihr hauptsächlich dass
sie sagen muss dass mit dem auto das ist
aber dass dann abhaken
ab und zu ja jetzt mache ich mir so lud
der abgewickelten moment
dann geht's endlich sind wir kurz team
ja das war keine haben
die eltern der fahrer hat julia schon
konfirmiert heute will er den ablauf der
trauung in der kirche mit dem paar
besprechen
liebe julia live-demo ihr werdet eure
liebe vor gott und vor der gemeinde
bestätigen und um sie in sagen die dafür
ihre gemeinsame lebenswerk gott hat euch
schafe durch jesus christus sind hier
zusammengeführt
sie stärkt und begleitete und dann will
ich der eben zuerst fragen verspricht
die julia preuß halter sitz hier bei uns
aktuell die otto schenk wird dann sagt
sie oh ja eigentlich auch julia sprichst
du im remo treue zahlt ins leben und 80
all die jahre durch schranke wird dann
sag ja
ja ich will mit dem kind das sie
versprach dass die junge frau hat mutig
und elizabeth ii
er verspricht infos an
das ist doch gut dass er ja ganz gerührt
bis zu unterwegs
also wie schätzt das wasser studie
vorgestellt wurde lang verschiedene
möglichkeiten natürlich natürlich schön
werden
damit trage und schnitte zeige ich
schöne und nicht perfekt
sehr schöne und sehr ihr wunsch sie
immer relativ sicher
es ist einfach schwierig
[Gelächter]
es ist zwar schön aus
damit ist er ja dann nein warum noch
lange danach ohne mich falls hier
richtung das pflaster was bewirkt und
das heißt dass ich ein holzgestell und
das verhindert aus ist keine mediale
aufregung
und bremste vor noch ziemlich stark
[Musik]
schön dass sie stark die triller und
konfirmiert und und mit rinde
regelmäßige quint das schön finde das
schön wenn sie das sagen vorbote für die
bezieher stoff das ist jetzt der buga
hoch denn immer noch die hutfarbe besser
ob der babybauch ist für das pasolini
stück die 120 tage von sodom julia und
das ensemble spielen auf der
schauspielbühne auch mit diesem stück
werden sie weit über die landesgrenzen
hinaus bekannt
[Musik]
regie führt milo rau in den medien ist
er idee von einem skandal
aber themen wie gewalt und unterwerfung
bewältigen die profis vom hurra theater
souverän mit großer spiellust ich bin
gespannt
duschen attraktiver wird eine büste
gesehen zu werden
man sieht nichts
die ist voll bedeckt und demi moore ist
in wels da also ganz hohe ganz entspannt
durch die schwangerschaft einem stück um
liebe und der abtrieb systeme eigentlich
und natürlich wäre es sehr berührend
popkulturelles bildmotive verlauf und
eine gleiche wie zusammengesetzte
raumklima
[Gelächter]
mit viel würde und edel tuner ritterin
[Musik]
nie geschafft nennenswerte zukäufe werke
tropft noch immer zu mir so genau der
zuverlässig nur drauf
werfen wir einen blick für das resultat
dieser typ super weil das ich bin ja ok
red wie man eine filmszene sagen was nur
ganz schönes entdecken
ich glaube das plakat ist sport das
gewehr natürlich voraus während machen
aber ich kann versprechen plakaten ziel
steht halb zehn grad besprechen ich
glaube aber dachte schon an das projekt
wahrscheinlich dass jesus durch das
ganze stück reicht also warum starren
auf die er sagte während des also für
mich verständlich voll braucht wenn man
anfangs wenig mäßig alle behinderten
triebe mit pränataldiagnostik kritisiert
das total
da ist ein zeichen des so krass dass
betriebe werden aber naja ich jeden
wieso und und und das wird mir besucht
wie soep ist nun mal die kulisse ist und
zeige der weltgeschichte normal ist ihr
ex waren und mit drin bleiben ich jetzt
kein wie soll ich sagen ich spiele kein
konservativer irgendwie schon immer der
betriebe kritisiert dass ich mal so
gemacht
ich merke aber dass es ein absoluter
widerspruch geht zwischen der beschluss
ist phänomen wie wir heute link kultur
ist eine extrem gelobt wird wo alle
prise berühmt und auf der andere sieht
einen unausgesprochenen konsens dass die
menschen verschwinden
[Musik]
ich mache seinen job auf was muss dann
auch gut so so einfach so
sommer 2017 julia ist 25 jahre alt
ihr größter wunsch hat sich erfüllt
[Musik]
dies könnte noch ausreichen
unter tun ich habe ich sozusagen sprach
gott sagen das war für mich ein einsamer
werk scheint keine leichtigkeit von tanz
kraft vor der luft um gute bilder unter
die 4
[Applaus]
[Musik]